[Music]
all my cats playing man you know to be
honest he's probably the closest thing
that I've seen since Michael Vick this
guy is extremely dynamic can make plays
when you don't think there's a play
there to be made
he just Houdini I guess but phenomenal
not just with his legs but his ability
Bay to get the ball down the field as
well Steve walks the Browns offensive
our defense coordinator rather getting
ready to face Lamar Jackson in the
Ravens offense this weekend a lot of
pressure on them we are drafting who's
under the most pressure for week four of
the 2019 NFL season in big cat you know
how we do the first pick now trivia
question are you ready yes last night
was the first home game that Aaron
Rodgers lost with a double-digit lead he
had been 50 0 and 1 Tom Brady actually
180 straight home games in that same
situation double-digit lead from 2001
through 2015 which team ended his streak
hmm
Seahawks the Eagles
oh no the Eagles same team that ended
this remark the trick the same yeah the
Eagles went up there and took care of
the Patriots and the they were down 14
nothing and came back to win the game in
New England all right so I get the first
pick who's under the most pressure this
week I'm gonna start with the game we
talked about earlier a do or die game
for the two teams involved the Tennessee
Titans and the Atlanta Falcons both one
and two
I think the Titans are gonna win this
game and I think Dan Quinn had better do
everything he can to will the Falcons to
win the game because if they fall to 1
and 3 if the bottom starts to drop out
he's a guy who moves toward the top of
the list as a candidate for being out
the door during the season we we see
maybe one a year and there's talking
there's a thought that maybe it's gonna
be Jay Gruden in Washington but I think
if the Falcons fall in 1 and 3 and lose
to the Titans on Sunday Dan Quinn is a
guy that we really have to start paying
attention to as potentially being done
during the year big pressure on him to
pull off the victory at home ok
never talking about another man's job
but I agree with that pic and I'll
actually stay in that game for my first
pick
I think it's Marcus Mariota I think
Marcus Mariota has had moments very
fleeting moments where he's looked like
a good NFL quarterback but those moments
feel like they're few and far between
now and you have Ryan Tannehill backing
him up an option that Mike Vrabel can go
to almost went to on Thursday night
football against the Jaguars if Marcus
Mariota gets benched without an injury
because he's been out for a lot of his
career with injuries if he's a healthy
bench and Ryan Tannehill takes over is
that kind of his career I don't know
because you don't get a lot of second
chances after that he would obviously
still be on the team and someone would
sign him after this year but in terms of
being a no-doubter
you know starting quarterback that could
be it and I think Marcus Mariota is
right on that line right now where if he
doesn't perform and he doesn't prove
that he can command that offense that it
will be Ryan Tannehill Mike Vrabel won't
be afraid to do that he and Jameis
Winston in the same boat I think where
if they don't stake their claims to
remaining starting quarterbacks in their
current cities they become guy who signs
with the team in March and then that
team drafts a guy in the first round in
April so you're maybe holding on to be
the starter and then you start bouncing
around and you're the backup and look it
pays well but I think that for both
Mariota and Winston this really is the
last year and it may be the last chance
for Mariota and last week that Thursday
night game he came out with an urgency
in the third quarter that made me think
somebody said to him at halftime
this is it you better wake it up now or
we are going to Tannehill and I think
that they will inch closer to that if he
continues to play with that kind of
nonchalance lackadaisical no urgency we
saw it in the fourth quarter last week
where they were down two scores and I
thought he believed it was the third
quarter at one point so I that's a good
pick and that was on my list as well I
gotta go with Freddie kitchens Freddie
kitchens put himself under pressure he's
not on the hot seat he's nowhere close
to being on the hot seat but when your
explanation for not calling a run when
you've got 1st and goal from the 4
you do for past plays when the
explanation is I'm new at this that
doesn't inspire a whole lot of
confidence in the fan base in Cleveland
there's a lot of different ways you
could play it you could say I made the
judgment each play that a pass was best
look they have a defense out there they
could stop the run if they think of runs
coming and we passed the ball then we
got a better chance of scoring you don't
say I'm new at this I'll get better
that's not the game that you play when
you're a head coach trying to inspire
confidence in the building and out of
the building that you're the right guy
so this is an opportunity you like the
Browns this week if the Browns win this
game we forget about a lot of the things
that happened last week but Freddie
kitchens had better lose that mindset of
I'm new at this you either have a job
coaching an NFL team or you don't and
there's plenty of guys out there who
wouldn't be new at it who aren't gonna
use that excuse and I'm gonna come in
and get it done if you can't yeah I
agree I had Freddie kitchens on my list
as well this is a big game for him a big
test an early test we've took we you
know all offseason everyone said the
Browns this Browns that this is what
comes with expectations when a team has
expectations and doesn't you know live
up to the hype early on questions gets
get thrown around and I think everyone
is committed to Baker Mayfield so it's
the guy standing next to Baker may feel
that it gets a lot of these bullets here
okay I will go with my next pick I'll go
with a double pick it's a double pick
because it's the same game Kirk Cousins
and mr. Biscay both of them together a
lot of pressure for them this game has
all the makings of being terrible
football tough to watch
- very good defenses two quarterbacks
trying to find their way and if one of
these guys can step up and steal this
moment I think that team that franchise
will feel a lot better going forward
with their future and on the on the
flipside if one of them falls on their
face there's gonna be a lot of questions
and a lot of angst and you know you can
you hear the rumblings already so I
think there's a lot of pressure on both
these guys facing very good defenses in
the same game see I look at it this way
if either of these guys is expected to
make a big play to win the game they're
gonna fail it's just a question of which
team is in position to be defending
when the other quarterback is in
position to make the big play to win the
game but but it still is a lot of
pressure because while you're right that
neither guy is expected to win the game
if either guy has a truly awful game
then it's like we because this is one of
those tests where both teams seem to be
good both defenses are good if you can't
win this game if you fall on your face
in this game then then you have to
actually ask can we can we keep going
with this guy going forward and the big
problem for Cousins and this may be the
problem for true Biscay as well that we
will learn over the passage of time he's
very aware of the pressure and he
changes in those moments the big games
on the road the primetime games the big
throw in the fourth quarter when you're
about to erase a 21-nothing deficit and
you throw into double coverage in the
end zone and blow the game he seems to
be highly aware of those moments and he
doesn't perform in those moments so in
that same vein I'm gonna put Daniel
Jones on the list as a guy who's under
pressure but not in a bad way look look
he has shown he can handle the pressure
but it's clearly pressure it's good
pressure you're coming in to make your
home debut there's an expectation you're
gonna win the game you had that great
performance last week how do you follow
it up how do you justify what you did
last week if you lose to Washington 24
to 14 and you're lackadaisical and
you're not inspiring
everybody's gonna forget about what
happened in Tampa Bay but if you come in
and you continue the Danny dimes or
Danny deuce routine or whatever it is
then you continue to be embraced by the
open arms of New York so this is an
opportunity for Daniel Jones to really
cement that bond that started last week
there's pressure there though because
they will quickly forget about him if he
comes out and plays poorly and as you
pointed out earlier he doesn't have se
Quan Barkley yeah no you're wrong on
this pick this is a terrible pick
because no you see you you liked it and
then while I was explaining you thought
I gotta come up with a way to crap on
him nothing really is a good pick I know
it's like a facial expression no I said
ooh you could you can go and replay it I
said ooh what is Mike doing right now
he's so stupid this is a dumb pic
Jones is a rookie it's his second game
if he does poorly you actually think the
Giants fans are gonna be like this guy
is not good anymore they're going to say
I as a fan myself you always do the
mental gymnastics to say well he's young
he's football young he's got a lot to
learn of course he has a step back we're
on to next week that's that is a badge
the pressure no the pressure comes from
the opportunity this is the equivalent
of the little brother who has the big
brother on the ropes in ping-pong he's
not expected to win but this is the
opportunity to do it you win this home
debut you get two two and two and all of
a sudden they're gonna feel even better
about you than they did last week if you
just look ordinary then they're gonna be
out last week was a fluke
okay the jury's still out on whether or
not this guy is gonna be good this is an
opportunity for him to take it next
level that's why there's pressure there
it's good pressure and I think he can
live up to it okay my last pick is the
one that's gonna win this draft the most
pressure this weekend Buffalo Bills fans
Buffalo Bills fans when the Patriots
come to town everyone expects for them
to put on a show everyone expects them
to be the loudest fans in the NFL I
think the Buffalo Bills fans have to
help their team win this game everyone
knows that it's not just the 22 guys on
the field it's the fans in the stands
that can help their team win the game
Buffalo Bills fans have a ton of
pressure on their team on themselves
this weekend and you know it's funny I
had on the list bills security because
of the annual Tom Brady identified
flying object game and Sims and I talked
about this earlier in the week and I
want to be careful not to go too far
back down that rabbit hole but there was
a certain item that multiple fans will
be trying to smuggle into the facility
and then throw onto the field and they
better number one if there's a way to do
it keep the items from coming in number
two they better intercept before they
get thrown onto the field and then
number three they better figure out who
did it and get him out of the stadium
because they've been arrests over this
but it there is no way that someone's
not gonna try to do it and I think
multiple people are gonna try to do it
as the bills mafia tries to take down
Tom Brady and the New England Patriots
yeah a lot of pressure I love Buffalo
it's gonna be a fun
it's always a fun atmosphere outside
there but you know they have to they
have to show up and they have to be very
loud because they got to give their team
any edge they can when they're trying to
beat the Patriots and Tom Brady was
pretty candid about it earlier in the
week he said he loves it when they go on
the road and they get up early and then
by the third and fourth quarter it's
only Patriots fans left that he relishes
that more than he relishes winning at
home so he gets a chance to do it again
on Sunday we're gonna take a quick break
when we return our favorite underdogs
and our favorite storylines of week four
we'll be back with more PFT live right
after this
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports